hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to talk about
speaking
how do we get to speak how do we get to
speak well
i often get this question because
many of you have heard me repeatedly
talk about the importance of input of
listening and reading of building up
your vocabulary building up your
comprehension if you can understand well
you'll have an easier time in
conversations
we need to understand before we can
speak all the stuff and you say yeah
fine fine fine but how do we get to
where we can speak and speak well
well there is a secret to speaking well
and it's very simple you have to speak a
lot you have to speak a lot uh if i look
at my own languages
those languages that i speak the best
are the ones that i have spoken the most
starting with english
and then of course french because i
studied there for three years as a
student i lived there i studied i had
listened to lectures i had to give my
oral presentations in french and so
forth
japanese because i lived there for nine
years did business in japanese
and chinese
because i studied it for a long time and
i've often had interaction with chinese
people here in vancouver
spanish is next but there after i have
really not spoken those languages very
much and the ones that i'm weakest in
the russian the czech and so forth the
portuguese i've rarely spoken those
languages so you want to speak well you
have to speak a lot it's that simple
now
how do you
you know get to where you can speak a
lot well for one thing
my advice is
you know to have a an artificial
conversation via skype where you're
talking about the weather
to my mind is less powerful
than
talking about things that are meaningful
and so i personally because i have a
limited amount of time that i can spend
in language learning
if i have an hour or two a day i'm far
more likely to spend that time on
easy to arrange
pleasurable interesting input activities
like listening and reading
and i tend to put off the speaking
until i'm in a situation where i have to
speak a lot
uh now
sometimes you can't do that i
wanted to prepare for going to prague so
i stepped up my online speaking i wanted
to go
to prepare for my visit to romania i
stepped up my online speaking
of romanian
but ultimately with a specific goal in
mind and that was to go to the country
where the language is spoken and to
speak a lot
because
you know it's it's fine and dandy to say
that speaking you know through skype is
great and it is it's amazing i have
wonderful conversations with my link
tutors in italian and portuguese i've
had them russian czech romanian and so
forth
but it's not the same as being face to
face with people
and particularly being with a group of
people
and so you have to put yourself in that
situation
yes you can also find groups wherever
you live
and and you want to be with native
speakers i personally am not a fan of
non-native speakers speaking to each
other showing off their language skills
uh if you are in a business situation
where you are speaking for a purpose
fine but setting up role-playing in
classrooms or or meeting with people to
talk in these languages that we're
learning
i personally find those less natural i
guess what i'm saying is
that i believe that in language learning
as much as possible i want to do things
that are meaningful and natural
and so i want to have a conversation
that's of interest to me i want to be in
a with a group of people even if i don't
understand
it's meaningful it's real
so i like to put myself in those real
and meaningful situations
um if the person replies to me in
english say if i'm in germany and the
person who replies to me in english fine
you know that's what they want to do the
the level of communication that we're
going to have is going to based on his
desires or hers gonna be in english fine
i'll find another person who'll speak to
me in german and i always do and i
always do okay
so
uh get yourself meaningful interaction
with native speakers normally that means
to me delaying when you start speaking
now when you're in a conversation you
you say i understand i can read but the
words i can't say what i want to say
well of course that's going to be the
case
and you're it's going to be that the
case for a long long time
uh i have a russian barber i go to him
so i can get my haircut and speak
russian i struggle especially if i've
been working on check or something else
i can't
get the words out the way i would like
however a big secret
however badly you think you're doing
you're probably not doing as badly as
you think you are in other words the
person who hears you speak probably
thinks you're doing very well
and
you know very often we tend to be very
critical of ourselves we're extremely
aware of our shortcomings of our
inability to find a word of our
you know inability to get the grammar
correct we sense all those things as
we're speaking but the other person says
wow this guy's a native speaker of some
other language and he's doing quite well
in my language and by and large
uh that's the reaction
so
one bit of advice is don't be too hard
on yourself you're probably doing better
than you think you are as long as you
are communicating you're doing fine
that's number one all right another
question that comes up how do i speak
like a native speaker
my answer is forget it you're not going
to speak like a native speaker you can
try to imitate the accent of the native
speaker get as close as you can
and that'll be good enough
i have i mean
even the person who i think is the the
superstar of the internet polyglots luca
the only language that i am a native
speaker of english he does not sound
like a native speaker he sounds like a
native speaker to me in other languages
but i don't know if he sounds like a
native speaker to speakers of those
languages it doesn't matter he
communicates wonderfully in all those
languages so
speaking you know sounding like a native
speaker is not a condition i had a
banker swiss
he used to come in with his british
assistant and come and visit us at the
office
he had a very stiff space to accentuate
the up and down
but he spoke english much better than
his british assistant his british
assistant from london
couldn't use words properly spoke you
know was a far less intelligent user of
the english language my swiss banker i
marveled at how well he used words how
well he expressed himself
and so
sounding like a native speaker should
not be a goal it's far more important
that you can use words effectively
another tip if you're in a conversation
especially if it's not business but if
it's a social event
you know lots of words are flying by you
you don't understand a lot of it it
doesn't matter
pick on those things that you do
understand and then respond to those
things
it's a great experience for you
you're picking up you're listening
you're trying to interact you're
interacting partially and if you do this
more and more often you will eventually
get better
but it's a long road it is a long road
if fluency means being comfortable
on a variety of subjects
expressing yourself understanding what
people are saying this is not a
three-month project it is a longer
project unless you are moving from say
spanish to portuguese or vice versa and
you're very dedicated it might move a
little faster but by and large in most
cases we're talking
i don't know 500 hours
for the more difficult languages a
thousand fifteen hundred dollars you
figured out how many hours a day can you
spend that's the kind of time investment
you have to make
do things that are natural do things
that are meaningful
um
give yourself credit for what you have
achieved don't
be harsh and too harsh on yourself
chances are you're doing a lot better
and i've had this experience many times
oh and and so the other thing about it
is when you're in a situation where
you're speaking a lot it's tiring it's
tiring if you go to the country and
you're speaking whatever french or
chinese from morning till night and
listening to it i mean your your throat
is more hoarse
than if you were speaking your own
language because everything is more
tense
you're tired you've been searching for
words
and you feel you've done poorly on top
of it all you've done extremely well
you've spoken in this language all day
long and you come back to your hotel
room or wherever you're staying and you
feel jesus jesus i couldn't say what i
wanted to say
forget it you're doing well plus
that is exactly the process whereby
you're going to improve
massive intense exposure to the language
but in order to be able to pull it off
you have to first
not only first invest in the
comprehension
skills but you have to continue to
invest in the comprehensive skills
because when you speak
you discover where your gaps are you
discover those things you weren't able
to say
if you have a conversation with the
tutor at link you actually get a report
with all the words and phrases that you
didn't use correctly now you got to
start
noticing those when you're listening and
reading so you continue doing your input
activities so that you can then
do better gradually there's no sudden
improvement you'll be corrected make the
same mistake again correct it make the
same mistake again doesn't matter and to
some extent the correction is kind of a
minor part of it what's more important
is that you're actually speaking and the
more you speak the better you get and
the more positive you are the less you
say i'm no good i can't speak i come i
couldn't find my words i always get this
wrong that wrong sure you're going to
get it wrong you'll continue to get it
wrong but
try to notice try to notice where you
had trouble where you have doubts about
the grammar look the grammar up it's not
so difficult today on the internet look
up the conjugation of somewhere did i
get the
ending right third person singular of
the past tense in spanish or something
look it up and you'll forget it again
and look it up again and forget it again
and keep trying to use it and this is a
gradual and slow process now i wonder i
made a couple of little notes here yeah
you know with regard to endings
declensions conjugations i always find
that
i mean we're concerned about the one
we're speaking because we want to get
them right
uh i find looking at the tables doesn't
help me a lot it's a very short-term
memory kind of thing
i find that
if i'm reading and i notice these
phrases with the correct ending certain
phrases will start to seem natural after
a while and and as you use them and use
them wrong and then you're aware of
that's a weakness and you're noticing
them while you're reading and listening
and slowly you start to use them more
accurately what else did i have written
down here
um
yeah and you want to continue with your
input input activities
a couple of things just to end off here
uh you know i made my previous video
about the importance of input and
passive vocabulary and someone said well
you know you shouldn't start
by reading because then you'll read
pronouncing it all wrong
when you start into a new language
listen and read
don't just
read
whatever you read you got to listen to
but whatever you listen to you should
read because one of the problems i have
with pimsleur is
if i hear it
i don't quite get it if i can hear it
and read it even though words are
spelled differently or the sounds are
represented differently by the writing
system if i can work the two together
and when you're starting in the language
you're dealing with very short snippets
listen and read always the same until
you're very well along in the language
um you know i'll do another one on
pronunciation because i think the main
discussion here today is how do you get
speaking well and so i want to emphasize
this you got to speak a lot and you
don't have to start speaking at the
beginning you start speaking when you
either want to or you have an
opportunity or you need to and so forth
and it helps too one other thing if i
remember my japanese experience it helps
to find a native speaker who's very
patient
where you are having meaningful
conversations but the person is patient
maybe speaks a little more slowly maybe
humors you where it would be easier to
speak in english if you find that person
that friend can be a tremendous
uh benefit but ultimately speak well
uh you have to speak a lot oh and i was
gonna say one thing more um
you know there are other people on the
internet who
offer advice
on how to get speaking
luca
is to my mind he's just phenomenal his
his russian now is chinese just
phenomenal he translates from his own
language into the target language
no from the target language into his own
language and then from his own language
back
you know i have a limited number of
hours in the day i'm not going to do
that because i like to do things that i
find interesting like reading about
czech history for example which i'm
doing today
but it's something you might want to
look at
there was a fellow i mentioned before a
chinese immigrant to canada who listened
to the same limited content a thousand
times i could never do that but he did
that i mean there are any number of
things there are people who read out
loud there's alex arges who
you know is very much a proponent of
shadowing look these things up if you
can do them i can't i just don't find i
just don't find the meaningful things to
do i like meaningful communication
meaningful listening and reading
meaningful talking when the opportunity
presents itself and just going for it
without worrying about how i sound
okay then thank you for listening bye
for now